[Music]
steroids their infamous for their use in
sports but they're also found in
inhalers creams to treat poison ivy and
eczema and shots to ease inflammation
the steroids in these medicines aren't
the same as the ones used to build
muscle in fact they're all based on yet
another steroid one our body produces
naturally and we can't live without
taking a step back the reason there are
so many different steroids is because
the term refers to substances with a
shared molecular structure rather than
shared effects on the body steroids can
be naturally occurring or synthetic but
what all steroids have in common is a
molecular structure that consists of a
base of four rings made of 17 carbon
atoms arranged in three hexagons and one
Pentagon a molecule must contain this
exact arrangement to be a steroid though
most also have side chains additional
atoms that can dramatically impact the
molecules function steroids get their
name from the fatty molecule cholesterol
in fact our bodies make steroids out of
cholesterol that fatty cholesterol base
means that steroids are able to cross
fatty cell membranes and enter cells
within the cell they can directly
influence gene expression and protein
synthesis this is different from many
other types of signaling molecules which
can't cross the cell membrane and have
to create their effects from outside the
cell through more complicated pathways
so steroids can create their effects
faster than those other molecules back
to the steroids in anti-inflammatory
medications all of these are based on a
naturally occurring steroid called
cortisol cortisol is the body's primary
stress signal and it has a huge range of
functions when we experience a stressor
anything from a fight with a friend to
spotting a bear to an infection or low
blood sugar the brain reacts by sending
a signal from the hypothalamus to the
pituitary gland
the pituitary gland then sends a signal
to the adrenal glands the adrenal glands
produce cortisol and release some
constantly but when they receive the
signal from the pituitary gland they
release a burst of cortisol which Spurs
the body to generate more glucose for
energy decrease functions not
immediately related to survival like
digestion and can activate a fight
flight or freeze response this is
helpful in the short term but can cause
undesirable side effects like insomnia
and lowered mood if they last too long
cortisol also interacts with the immune
system in complex ways depending on the
situation it can increase or decrease
certain immune functions in the process
of fighting infection the immune system
often creates inflammation cortisol
suppresses the immune system's ability
to produce inflammation which again can
be useful in the short term but too much
cortisol can have negative impacts like
reducing the immune system's ability to
regenerate bone marrow and lymph nodes
to prevent levels from staying high for
too long cortisol suppresses the signal
that causes the adrenal glands to
release more cortisol medicinal
corticosteroids channel cortisol's
effects on the immune system to fight
allergic reactions rashes and asthma all
these things are forms of inflammation
there are many synthetic steroids that
share the same basic mechanism they
enhance the body's cortisol supply which
in turn shuts down the hyperactive
immune responses that cause inflammation
these corticosteroids sneak into cells
and can turn off the fire alarm by
suppressing gene expression of
inflammatory signals the steroids in
inhalers and creams impact only the
affected organ the skin or the lungs
intravenous or oral versions used to
treat chronic autoimmune conditions like
lupus or inflammatory bowel disease
impact the whole body with these
conditions the body's immune system
attacks its own cells a process
analogous to a const
asthma attack or rash a constant low
dose of steroids can help keep this
renegade immune response under control
but because of the negative
psychological and physiological effects
of long-term exposure higher doses are
reserved for emergencies and flare-ups
while an asthma attack
poison ivy welts and irritable bowel
syndrome might seem totally unrelated
they all have something in common an
immune response that's doing more harm
than good
and while corticosteroids won't give you
giant muscles they can be the body's
best defense against itself but why
exactly do some body's attack themselves
your immune system is there to protect
you right not always take a closer look
at what causes seasonal allergies with
this video or learn more about asthma
with this video
[Music]